even while there are some positive news
on curbing the spread of kovat 19 in
some countries in Asia Pacific like
South Korea it saw the fewest new
infection cases since its peak in
February many more nations are moving
forward on shutting down non-essential
businesses and restricting movement
Indonesia just began a two-week
emergency period and Hong Kong will ban
foreign arrivals for 14 days starting on
Wednesday this after a recent spike in
coronavirus cases mostly imported the
increasing economic impact on the region
and the still unresolved 2 trillion
dollar US rescue package forced most
major asian stock markets down as the
new trading week started captains of
industry leaders of Union Australia has
implemented strict restrictions on
non-essential services and social
gatherings so together and with the rest
of the world we face this unprecedented
challenge a once in a hundred year event
a global health pandemic that has vast
become an economic crisis the likes of
which we have not seen since the Great
Depression
New Zealand moved into its highest
possible alert level restricting
movement and shutting schools to be
absolutely clear we are now asking all
New Zealanders who are outside essential
services to stay at home and to stop all
interaction with others outside of those
in your household joining other major
international air carriers Singapore
Airlines announced that it will slash
its capacity by 96% grounding nearly all
of its fleet it's a catastrophic
situation January traffic was pretty
normal but February numbers traffic in
Asia fell by about 50 percent and that's
deteriorated further as we've gone
through March because more and more
countries are obviously focusing on
fighting the the corona virus outbreaks
and as a result of imposed they're more
and more onerous their border
restrictions Singapore Airlines move
comes after the country closed its
borders to travelers even transiting
passengers in order to curb the spread
of the virus
Scott Heidler al-jazeera